Il variational quantum eigensolver, o VQE, è uno dei primi algoritmi ibridi quantistico-classici ed è
interessante per diversi motivi. Primo, come vedremo in questo video, è un approccio promettente per alcuni tipi di problemi. In secondo luogo, è importante
storicamente e ha aperto la strada a molti algoritmi migliorati come adapt VQE.
E infine, VQE è abbastanza semplice. È facile capire cosa fanno i computer quantistici e classici in questo algoritmo
e come interagiscono. Ci sono quattro componenti principali di un calcolo VQE.
Prima di tutto, c'è un operatore, spesso un Hamiltoniano, che chiameremo H, che descrive una proprietà del sistema che
si vuole ottimizzare. Un altro modo per dirlo è che stai cercando l'autovettore di questo operatore che
corrisponde all'autovalore minimo. Spesso chiamiamo quell'autovettore lo stato fondamentale.
Poi c'è un ansatz, parola che significa approccio. Questo è un circuit quantistico che prepara uno stato quantistico che approssima
l'autovettore che stai cercando. In realtà l'ansatz è una famiglia di circuit quantistici perché alcuni dei gate in
esso sono parametrizzati. Cioè, ricevono un parametro che possiamo variare. Questa famiglia di circuit quantistici
può preparare una famiglia di stati quantistici che approssimano lo stato fondamentale.
Poi abbiamo bisogno di uno stimatore, un mezzo per stimare il valore di aspettazione dell'operatore H sullo stato quantistico variazionale corrente.
A volte ciò che ci interessa davvero è semplicemente questo valore di aspettazione, che
chiamiamo funzione di costo. Altre volte ci interessa una funzione più complicata che può comunque essere scritta partendo da
uno o più valori di aspettazione.
Infine, abbiamo bisogno di un ottimizzatore classico, un algoritmo che varia i parametri per cercare di minimizzare questa funzione di costo.
Descriviamo il problema che vogliamo risolvere e l'approccio generale prima di affrontare il ruolo del quantum. Possiamo
formulare molti problemi di ottimizzazione critici per la scienza e l'industria come problemi di valori di matrice. Di solito
si vuole l'autovalore minimo della matrice e l'autovettore corrispondente. La matrice H potrebbe essere
un Hamiltoniano che descrive l'energia di un sistema fisico. E l'autovalore minimo sarebbe l'energia dello stato fondamentale
E0 e l'autovettore sarebbe il corrispondente stato fondamentale quantistico, spesso indicato come PSI sub 0.
Oppure la matrice potrebbe descrivere una funzione di costo complicata associata a problemi di ottimizzazione combinatoria
come in logistica, e l'autostato s subopt sarebbe una soluzione ottimale del
problema, come una stringa binaria che etichetta un taglio in un grafo di una rete di distribuzione. In pratica
è comune sentire il termine Hamiltoniano usato per tutte le matrici di interesse anche al di fuori delle scienze fisiche. Supponiamo
di essere interessati a una matrice con n righe e n colonne. Tali problemi possono essere risolti rapidamente ed esattamente usando
solver classici per n fino a qualche centinaia o migliaio senza fare assunzioni sulla matrice. Per matrici sparse,
quelle con principalmente zeri come elementi, questo può essere molto più grande con n fino a un miliardo anche su un laptop.
Ma per problemi veramente enormi che superano questi numeri, spesso sono necessari metodi approssimativi o euristici.
Più grande è la matrice e meno è sparsa, meno trattabile è il problema e più trucchi intelligenti devono essere impiegati. Supponi che la tua matrice sia così
grande che la diagonalizzazione esatta non sia un'opzione. Supponi inoltre di sapere abbastanza sul tuo problema da poter
fare alcune ipotesi sulla struttura generale dello stato target e di voler sondare stati simili alla tua
ipotesi iniziale per vedere se il costo o l'energia possono essere ulteriormente abbassati. Questo è un approccio variazionale ed è un metodo
usato quando la diagonalizzazione esatta non è un'opzione usando un computer classico. Funzionerebbe così.
Primo, fai uno stato di ipotesi con alcuni parametri theta che varierai.
Sebbene questa ipotesi iniziale potrebbe essere casuale, non è consigliabile. Vogliamo usare la conoscenza del problema in questione
per adattare la nostra ipotesi il più possibile.
Secondo, calcoleresti il valore di aspettazione dell'operatore con il sistema in quello stato.
Terzo, altereresti i parametri variazionali e ripeteresti.
Quarto, useresti le informazioni accumulate sul paesaggio dei possibili stati nel tuo sottospazio variazionale per fare ipotesi sempre migliori
e avvicinarti allo stato target.
Il principio variazionale garantisce che il nostro stato variazionale non possa produrre un autovalore inferiore a quello dello
stato fondamentale target. Quindi più basso è il valore di aspettazione, migliore è la nostra approssimazione dello stato fondamentale.
Parliamo della difficoltà di ogni passaggio in questo approccio.
Impostare o aggiornare i parametri è computazionalmente facile. La difficoltà sta nel selezionare parametri iniziali utili fisicamente
motivati. Usare le informazioni accumulate dalle iterazioni precedenti per aggiornare i parametri in modo tale
da avvicinarsi allo stato fondamentale non è banale. Ma esistono algoritmi di ottimizzazione classica che lo fanno
abbastanza efficientemente. Questa ottimizzazione classica è costosa solo perché potrebbe richiedere molte
iterazioni. Nel caso peggiore, il numero di iterazioni potrebbe scalare esponenzialmente con n.
Il singolo passaggio computazionalmente più costoso è quasi certamente il valore di aspettazione della tua matrice usando un
dato stato. La matrice n per n deve agire sul vettore di n elementi, il che corrisponde a circa n al quadrato
operazioni di moltiplicazione nel caso peggiore. Questo deve essere fatto a ogni iterazione dei parametri. Per matrici
estremamente grandi, questo ha un costo computazionale elevato. Ora immagina di affidare questa parte del
calcolo a un computer quantistico. Invece di calcolare questo valore di aspettazione, lo stimi preparando lo
stato s di theta sul computer quantistico usando il tuo ansatz variazionale e poi facendo misurazioni.
Analizziamo un po' questo. H in generale non è facile da misurare. Ad esempio, potrebbe essere composto da molti
operatori di Pauli x, y e z non commutanti.
Ma H può essere scritto come combinazione lineare di termini H sub alfa, ognuno dei quali è facilmente misurabile. Ad esempio,
operatori di Pauli o gruppi di operatori di Pauli che commutano bit per bit. Il
valore di aspettazione di H sullo stato S è la somma pesata dei valori di aspettazione dei termini costituenti H alfa.
Questa espressione vale per qualsiasi stato s, ma la useremo specificamente con il nostro stato variazionale s di theta.
Ognuno dei termini h alfa può essere misurato m volte, producendo campioni di misurazione s sub alfa j con j che va
da 1 a m, e restituisce un valore di aspettazione e una deviazione standard. Possiamo sommare
questi termini e propagare gli errori attraverso la somma.
Questo non richiede moltiplicazioni su larga scala né alcun processo che scala necessariamente come n al quadrato. Al contrario,
richiede misurazioni multiple sul computer quantistico. Se non ne hai bisogno di troppe, questo approccio potrebbe essere
efficiente. E questa è la parte quantistica del VQE. Ma parliamo dei motivi per cui potrebbe non essere efficiente. Un motivo
per molte misurazioni è ridurre l'incertezza statistica nelle tue stime per calcoli ad alta precisione.
Un altro motivo è il numero di stringhe di Pauli necessarie per coprire l'intera matrice. Poiché le matrici di Pauli più
l'identità coprono lo spazio di tutti gli operatori di una data dimensione, siamo garantiti
che possiamo scrivere la nostra matrice di interesse come somma pesata di operatori di Pauli come abbiamo fatto prima. Qui C alfa è un
coefficiente numerico e H alfa è una stringa di operatori di Pauli che agisce su tutti i qubit che descrivono il tuo sistema.
H alfa avrebbe una forma come questa, dove l'n-esimo operatore di Pauli da destra agisce sull'n-esimo qubit. Quindi possiamo
misurare il nostro operatore misurando una serie di operatori di Pauli. Ma non possiamo misurare tutti questi operatori di Pauli
simultaneamente. Gli operatori di Pauli esclusa l'identità non commutano tra loro se sono
associati allo stesso qubit. Ad esempio, possiamo misurare I Z, IIZ e ZZ
XZ simultaneamente perché possiamo misurare I e Z simultaneamente per il terzo
qubit. E possiamo conoscere I e X simultaneamente per il primo qubit. Ma non possiamo
misurare tutti Z e ZZ ZX simultaneamente perché Z e X non
commutano e agiscono entrambi sul qubit zero.
Quindi decomponiamo la nostra matrice H in una somma di Pauli che agiscono su qubit diversi.
Alcuni elementi di quella somma possono essere misurati tutti insieme. Chiamiamo questo un gruppo di Pauli che commutano. A seconda
di quanti termini non commutanti ci sono, potremmo aver bisogno di molti di questi gruppi. Chiamiamo il numero di tali gruppi di Pauli commutanti t.
t.
Se ngcp è piccolo, questo potrebbe funzionare bene.
Se h ha milioni di gruppi, non sarà utile. Registri il valore di aspettazione o la funzione di costo
per l'insieme di parametri theta usati nel tuo stato e poi aggiorni i parametri nel tempo. Potresti usare i
valori di aspettazione o i valori della funzione di costo che hai stimato per approssimare un gradiente della tua funzione di costo nel
sottospazio degli stati campionati dal tuo ansatz.
Esistono ottimizzatori classici sia basati sul gradiente che senza gradiente. Entrambi soffrono di potenziali problemi di addestrabilità come
minimi locali multipli e grandi regioni dello spazio dei parametri con gradiente quasi zero chiamate barren plateau.
Quindi VQE risolverà tutti i tuoi problemi più difficili? No. Ma essere migliori in tutti i calcoli non è mai stato il punto. Abbiamo
cambiato ciò che determina il costo computazionale. Guarda cosa abbiamo scambiato. Siamo passati da un processo
la cui complessità dipende solo dalla dimensione della matrice a uno che dipende dalla precisione richiesta e dal numero di
operatori di Pauli non commutanti che compongono la matrice. Quest'ultimo aspetto non ha analoghi nel calcolo classico.
Sulla base di queste nuove dipendenze, per matrici sparse o matrici con poche stringhe di Pauli non commutanti, questo
processo potrebbe essere utile. Questo è il caso dei sistemi di spin interagenti. Ad esempio, per matrici dense potrebbe essere
meno utile. Sappiamo, ad esempio, che i sistemi chimici hanno spesso Hamiltoniani che coinvolgono centinaia, migliaia o persino
milioni di stringhe di Pauli. Sono stati fatti lavori interessanti per ridurre questo numero di termini, ma
i sistemi chimici potrebbero essere più adatti ad alcuni degli altri algoritmi di cui parleremo in questo corso.
Un uso efficace del VQE richiede anche che conosciamo gli attributi del nostro stato target e possiamo selezionare un buono stato iniziale fisicamente
motivato, nonché un buon ansatz con relativamente pochi parametri variazionali. Questo può essere
abbastanza impegnativo. VQE dimostra come i punti di forza dei computer classici e quantistici possono essere combinati
senza aggiungere metodi più recenti. VQE non ci aiuta a risolvere problemi intrattabili per i computer classici, ma
continua a svolgere un ruolo nello sviluppo degli algoritmi. E VQE ci insegna anche che trasferire un passaggio dai computer classici
a quelli quantistici non è né meglio né peggio per tutti gli scopi. Piuttosto,
cambia quali fattori determinano l'efficienza del tuo algoritmo. Questa è un'importante lezione generale nel
calcolo ibrido quantistico-classico.